eine breaking news und zwar gibt es eine
geiselnahme in der ukraine
dort wurde ein bus mit mindestens 20
passagieren jetzt als geisel genommen
ich möchte direkt schalten in die
ukraine zu denn ist robert scott der
dort ist das was genau ist gerade was
geht vor sich in der ukraine was ist
passiert
das ist natürlich eine ganz tragische
sie trotzdem würde ich sagen wir haben
da im grunde genommen mit
höchstwahrscheinlich mit einem
linksextremisten zu tun der irgendwie
wirklich schon irgend welchen konkreten
hintergrund und bassist bus quasi
genommen hat da gibt es ungefähr zehn
passagiere details als geister sind
und der ist bewaffnet hat sie auch ein
automat und hat auch granaten mit sich
und das ist natürlich eine völlig
ungefährliche situation also diese man
hat angeblich auch mal ein ziemlich sexy
mythisches buchen der vergangenheit
geschrieben und wie gesagt er hat jetzt
keine großartig konkreten forderungen
also im grunde genommen ist es ist es
für einen protest gegen das system und
da versucht jetzt die nationalgarde den
bus zu umkreisen und irgendwas zu machen
aber wirklich herausgekommen ist dabei
noch wenig dass es bleibt eine ganz
gefährliche situation und eben die
tatsache dass diese man offenbar sehr
unberechenbar ist macht das ganze viel
komplizierter den cage bei mir im studio
jetzt julian röcker um über die neuesten
bilder die wir jetzt haben zu sprechen
können diese damen uns jetzt vor kurzem
erst erreicht wir sehen immer mehr
einsatzkräfte die jetzt vor ort sind
kannst du für uns noch einmal anpassen
was wir bisher überhaupt über das noch
immer anhaltende geiseldrama wissen ja
also wir wissen dass heute morgen
offenbar ein mann einen bus betreten hat
in der stadt
lutz gehört das ist im westen der
ukraine so seien ein riesiges land aber
im nordwesten der ukraine
der mann hat dann offenbar um 9 uhr 25
die polizei selber angerufen und hat
gesagt hallo ich war seinen namen
genannt
maxime hat er sich genannt also maxim
der böse und hatten gesagt ich habe hier
geiseln genommen und sie müssen jetzt
herkommen so also ganz normal die
polizei angerufen seitdem ist die
situation dort wir haben die 20 sind es
gibt auch mittlerweile einige bilder die
zeigen dass es einschusslöcher in der
scheibe gibt es ist nicht klar wer
geschossen hat also ob von außen
geschossen wurde oder ob der täter schon
selbst in die in die gegend geschossen
hat wir sehen noch auf vielen fotos dass
das die die vorhänge geschlossen sind
das buch das man kann also ganz schlecht
reingucken 925 ist tatsächlich auch eine
schlimme zeit also ich bin sehr oft in
der ukraine und die leute haben dort
wenige autos also für weniger als bei
uns am anteil an der bevölkerung und
diese busse sind wirklich voll also
jetzt sind wir 20 menschen drinnen man
weiß nicht welche rausgekommen sind am
anfang aber diese busse sind extrem voll
so dass man auch an normalen tagen nicht
durchgucken kann weil da sitzen menschen
da stehen menschen drin und man sich
auch ein relativ kleiner bus also da hat
er sozusagen die hauptverkehrszeit
abgepasst gibt es ja mittlerweile
bereits forderungen von dem geiselnehmer
es gibt keine forderungen des
geiselnehmers aber wir wissen immer mehr
über seinen hintergrund über das wasser
also gemacht hat und das sieht ja ich
bin kein psychologe ich kann sich bei
also sieht verstörend aus ganz
vorsichtig auszudrücken also er hat wohl
mittlerweile es gegen die ukrainischen
behörden davon aus dass es ein mann ist
der biss der im jahr 2014 ein buch
geschrieben hat mit dem titel die
philosophie des verbrechens und in
diesem buch beschreibt ja einmal seine
sein seinen gefängnisaufenthalt da sagst
du vorher im gefängnis und beschreibt
dass man ihn dort nicht bessern konnte
im gefängnis die ukrainische bern haben
mittlerweile auch gesagt dass er schon
vor 2014 in behandlung war aufgrund
psychischer erkrankungen
er selbst sagt sie versuchen seit 15
jahren mich zu heilen aber sie haben es
nicht geschafft in diesem buch
beispielsweise das ist ja ziemlich
verstörend er vergleicht sich selber mit
mit mit gott mit jesus in diesem buch er
sagt wenn ich in den spiegel sehen sich
das antlitz gottes und das passt ganz
gut so etwas zu sagen was wir
recherchiert haben nämlich dass er nicht
bloß bei facebook sondern auch bei
youtube sein bekenner video gepostet hat
vor
gestern kurz noch mal anschauen bevor
wir weiter darüber sprechen
es ist der tag des anti systems lügen
sie sich nicht selbst an feiern sie die
wahrheit dass also das video das der
gepostet hatte und jetzt gerne was wir
jetzt bisher darüber herausgefunden
haben also wir sind noch nicht ganz
sicher was er gesagt hat weil er spricht
zu einer mischung aus ukrainisch und
russisch was auch interessant ist weil
er wohnt eigentlich eine west ukraine
dagegen die meisten menschen ukrainisch
er selbst hat aber sein buch vorsicht
beispielsweise geschrieben also ist
nicht ganz klar und er sagt wir haben
übersetzen mit es ist der tag des
antriebssystems wir haben aber noch mal
genau reingehört und das könnte auch
reichen heißen stimmung an die systeme
und das würde bedeuten herzlichen
glückwunsch zum tag des anti systems und
das wurde passend zu dem was er später
sagt feiert ja also sozusagen ihr
gratuliert sich selber r gratuliert der
menschheit zu seinem akt den ihr dort
verfasst hat was ich gerade sagen wollte
ist dass der youtube channel wo er das
veröffentlicht hat er wurde vor einer
woche ein weiteres video veröffentlicht
und auf dem view hat er einen tick tock
video gepostet wo er sich wo er das eine
szene zu sehen wie jesus christus in
einem film vor vor einem kaiser steht
und sich um die verantworten muss und
jemand schreibt mit und er hat aber eine
eigene texte gesprochen also er sieht
sich selber sozusagen als dieser jesus
christus der sich dort rechtfertigt und
das system als den kaiser oder ähnlich
ist ja das ist noch schwer zu sagen auf
jeden fall das was wir bisher hören ist
sehr verstörend was es noch gibt bis
heute ist sein twitter-account von
damals der wurde noch nicht gelöscht
facebook-account mittlerweile wurde
gelöscht
und da schreibt ja auch deshalb nur zwei
veröffentlichungen dort gepackt das eine
sagt ich habe ein buch geschrieben um
das verhältnis von kriminalität und
freiheit zu aufzuarbeiten und das zweite
ist besonders verstörend da sagte was
ist diese freiheit diese freiheit ist
das paradies aber wie erreicht man das
paradies in dem man ein krimineller wird
und das ist schon ja also das ist schon
man wenn man es heute sieht aber wie
oft wenn man es heute sieht dann denkt
man das sind ja wirklich warnzeichen die
einem dort entgegen
schreien und das schon vor sechs jahren
wir haben auch ein tweet von ihm selber
noch mal von diesem twitter-account eben
kannst du uns ein bisschen mehr dann
auch sagen darüber was er eben schreibt
wir sehen jetzt hier immer mehr tweets
natürlich die passieren die kommentare
vor allem ja genau also ich bin mir
jetzt gerade nicht ganz sicher weil das
ist jetzt ein sehr neuer account den wir
hier sehen
ich habe seinen alten account aus dem
jahr 2014 also auf einmal gibt zwei
verschiedene wenn das jetzt tatsächlich
schon sein sollte wo ich mir nicht
sicher bin weil wir bloß ein zahlencode
haben oder einen großen code haben und
dann auch alle journalisten vielleicht
möglich auf jeden fall dass wir auf
jeden fall nicht sein alter sein alter
account aber was er sagt es ist
tatsächlich ist tatsächlich dass er
versucht diese ganze welt sozusagen zu
sagen ihr könnt mich nicht ändern also
er sagt auch immer wieder ja mag ich
kann das ist ganz wichtig dass sie das
steht auch so einem alten
twitter-account auch drauf als so eine
art so eine art zeichen sozusagen
sondern rundliches zeichen mit jammer du
also ich kann und dazu sagt ja auch
früher immer gesagt ihr könnt ihr könnt
mich töten aber ihr könnt mich nicht
heilen
ich bin immer ich denn ich kann ich kann
weil es eine einzige sache gibt die ich
nicht kann und das ist kein verbrecher
zu sein
also wenn man sich das anguckt wirklich
dann sind da wirklich eine ganz tiefe
störung bei dem herrn vorzulegen vielen
dank höheren für die ersten einblicke
die lage ist also weiterhin sehr
unübersichtlich man weiß auch noch immer
nicht ob es verletzte oder vielleicht
sogar schon tote geht wir werden sie
natürlich jederzeit auf dem laufenden
halten
zu dieser geiselnahme in der ukraine auf
bild.de alle entwicklungen an alle
informationen dazu und damit möchte ich
mich für den moment verabschieden die
kollegen sind dann um 18 uhr mit dem
nächsten bild lifenews zurück aber wie
gesagt bis dahin alle informationen
natürlich wie immer auf bild.de